From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low, sitting in for Ira Glass. The story of Sara and Ethan's relationship starts with heartbreak. She had just gotten out of a 12-year relationship. He was separated after 13 years of marriage. Neither of them were particularly interested in jumping into something new too fast. But their mutual friends thought, hey, they have that in common. They're both in their 40s, both a little wobbly from their last relationships. They should date. Here's Ethan.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。我是托宾·洛，代班伊拉·格拉斯。萨拉和伊桑的恋情始于心碎。萨拉刚结束一段12年的感情，而伊桑在13年的婚姻破裂后分居。两人当时都没心思迅速投入新恋情。但他们的共同朋友觉得，嘿，他们有共同点啊。两人都四十多岁，在上一段感情中都有点受挫。他们应该约会。下面是伊桑的声音。
I think they saw us both as people who didn't know what they were doing and thought, maybe these two can figure it out together.
我想他们把我们看作那种不知道自己在做什么的人，觉得也许我们俩能在一起摸索出个名堂。
That's both sweet and maybe a little insulting.
这话既贴心，可能也带点冒犯。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm going to take it as sweet.
是啊。不过，我打算把它当作贴心的话来听。
They hit it off, kept seeing each other, doing date-y stuff-- dinners, museums, walks in the park. And as weeks and then months went by, they advanced to the stage of hanging out with no particular plans. At one point, a kind of big thing happened. A friend of Sarah's died. Ethan knew how hard she was taking it, so he asked her, you want to go to a ball game, take your mind off things? And it felt nice to let him take care of her in that way. It's now been 10 months.
他们一拍即合，继续见面，做些约会该做的事——吃饭、逛博物馆、公园散步。随着周复一周、月复一月过去，他们进入了不需要具体计划也能消磨时间的阶段。有一次，发生了一件大事。萨拉的一位朋友去世了。伊桑知道萨拉很难过，于是问她：“想去球场看看吗？转换一下心情。”能让他以那种方式照顾自己，萨拉觉得很温暖。现在已经过去10个月了。
So you're in contact pretty much every day. You see each other regularly. You're not seeing anybody else. Is he your boyfriend, then?
所以你们几乎每天都有联系，经常见面，也没有和其他人交往。那他算是你的男朋友吗？
No.
不算。
Obviously, this is Sara.
显然，这位是萨拉。
What do you refer to him as?
你平时怎么称呼他？
I guess, I use his name.
我想，我叫他的名字。
OK.
好吧。
And I will often say, he's the person I'm sort of seeing.
我通常会说，他是我“约会的人”。
The "sort of" feels crucial there.
这里的“约会”二字感觉很关键。
Or kind of. Or I guess, I'm-- there's always a bit of a qualifier.
或者“那种关系”。或者我想，我总是会带点限定词。
Gosh. I think both of us have avoided using the boyfriend-girlfriend terms.
天哪，我想我们俩都在避免使用“男朋友”、“女朋友”这样的称呼。
In fact, a couple weeks ago, they had a conversation about whether it was time to have the "what are we" conversation, and they decided to put it off. Ethan and Sara are your classic example of "let's not put a label on it." You know couples like this. And I understand that people do this, but I'm always a little like, why are you doing this dance? If it looks like a boyfriend duck and it quacks like a boyfriend duck, it's just a boyfriend duck, right?
事实上，几周前，他们还讨论过是否该谈谈“我们到底是什么关系”的话题，但他们决定先搁置一边。伊桑和萨拉是“让我们不要贴标签”的典型例子。你肯定认识这样的情侣。我理解人们为什么这样做，但我总是觉得，你们为什么非要玩这种文字游戏呢？如果它看起来像鸭子，叫起来像鸭子，那它就是只鸭子，对吧？
Some of my friends will refer to him as my boyfriend. But--
我有些朋友会称呼他为我的男朋友。但是——
You're making a face.
你露出了那种表情。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm not very comfortable with it.
我对这个称呼不太自在。
Why do you think that is? What does it bring up for you? What is the feeling?
你觉得为什么呢？这让你想到了什么？是什么感觉？
It feels like if we put a label on it, gosh, we're going into the tunnel again. It feels like it could last a long time. And that's a little scary. And if I'm someone's girlfriend, I want to be prioritized in a certain way. And I'm going to be reciprocal in that. It's not something that I'm comfortable with right now.
感觉一旦贴上标签，天哪，我们又要钻进那条隧道了。感觉这可能会持续很长时间。这有点让人害怕。如果我是某人的女朋友，我会希望在某些方面被优先对待，我也得做出同样的回应。这并不是我现在感到舒服的事情。
There are other considerations they're thinking about, like Ethan's daughter, who is 10 and still doesn't really know about Sara. He's thought a lot about what putting a label on this thing with Sara would trigger.
他们还在考虑其他因素，比如伊桑10岁的女儿，她还不知道萨拉的存在。他思考了很多关于给这段关系贴上标签会引发什么。
If Dad had a girlfriend, I think that that would feel very significant to her. Yeah, I think that that would-- I think it would feel like a big deal to a 10-year-old.
如果爸爸有了女朋友，我觉得这对她来说意义重大。是的，我觉得这对一个10岁的孩子来说是一件大事。
When I was hearing this described to me at first, I was like-- to be honest, I was like, oh, this sounds very teenager-y, immature. We don't want to call it anything. And now, the more that I've talked to you, it's like, oh, it's a very mature-- and being honest with yourself about what you want and what comes with putting a label on it.
起初听你这么描述时，老实说，我觉得这听起来很幼稚，像青少年一样。我们什么都不想定义。但现在，和你聊得越多，我就越觉得，这其实非常成熟，对自己想要什么以及贴上标签后会带来的后果有清醒的认知。
Oh, yeah. Absolutely. Because there's expectations. And having no expectations is so much nicer right now.
哦，是的，绝对是。因为随之而来的是期待。而现在什么都不期待，感觉好多了。
I get what she's saying. Labels-- they're powerful. They can distill you down to a single word, can get stuck on you without your permission. I still think about the day when my dad introduced me as "his husky boy." I thought about that label for years. Today on our show, we have a story of a woman who spent more than a decade trying to get a particular label put on her. And we see what happens when a label that's holding someone's life together gets peeled away. And also, today, I have the all-powerful label of host, so I am commanding you to stay with us.
我明白她的意思。标签确实很有力量。它们能把你简化成一个词，让你在不知不觉中被定型。我还记得我父亲把我介绍为“他的小壮汉”的那一天。那个标签我记挂了多年。今天节目里，我们将讲述一位女性的故事，她花了十多年时间试图让自己被贴上某个特定的标签。我们还会看到当一个支撑着某人生活的标签被剥离时会发生什么。另外，今天我拥有“主持人”这个至高无上的标签，所以我命令你们留下来继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act 1, "Last Shift." The label being assigned in this first story is temporary. It's a label that can feel meaningful and definitive. You know the thing will end, whatever it is. But temporary is also a flexible term. Your life on earth is temporary, but it can go on for 100 years.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，“最后的一班”。第一个故事里被分配的标签是暂时的。这是一个既有意义又具有决定性的标签。你知道事情终会结束，无论那是什么。但“暂时”也是一个灵活的词。你在地球上的生命也是暂时的，但它可以持续100年。
The temporary label plays an important role in the US immigration system for something called Temporary Protected Status, TPS. TPS is a status given to a country all at once. It allows eligible people from that country to live and legally work in the US if their home country has become unsafe or unstable, for instance, because of war or disaster. And if war or disaster goes on, TPS can be extended. For some countries, it's been extended for more than 25 years. Wars can last a long time. A 30-second earthquake can cause damage that takes years to recover from.
“临时”这个标签在美国移民系统中扮演着重要角色，即所谓的“临时保护身份”（TPS）。TPS是一项针对特定国家赋予的身份。如果一个人的祖国因战争或灾难等原因变得不安全或不稳定，该国符合条件的公民可以在美国居住并合法工作。如果战争或灾难持续，TPS可以延长。有些国家的TPS已经延长了超过25年。战争可能持续很久。一场30秒的地震可能导致需要数年才能恢复的损害。
Last week, the Trump administration succeeded in ending TPS for people from Haiti. A judge removed the last roadblock. It affected a huge number of people, more than 300,000 Haitians. Many have been here in jobs and lives far longer than anyone would consider temporary. So, 300,000 people were facing an end, all at once. Chana Joffe-Walt spent time last week with one of them at her job, a woman named Marie. And no one, including Marie, knew which day would be her very last on the job. Here's Chana.
上周，特朗普政府成功终止了海地人的TPS。法官移除了最后的障碍。这影响了大量人群，超过30万海地人。许多人在这里工作和生活的时间远超任何人所定义的“临时”。所以，30万人的生活突然面临终结。查娜·乔夫-沃尔特上周花时间采访了其中一位，她叫玛丽。没有人，包括玛丽自己，知道哪一天会是她在职的最后一天。下面是查娜的报道。
I had heard about Marie before I showed up at the nursing home in Boston. Her boss told me he was losing his best CNA-- the pride of the building, he said. CNA is a Certified Nursing Assistant. Families love Marie, he told me. When I walked in, the senior nurse leader, Fleurinette, walked me up to the second floor, pointing out details and people along the way. And she pointed to a room and said, the woman staying in this room refused to be moved from her chair to the bed by anyone but Marie.
我在去波士顿那家疗养院之前就听说过玛丽。她的老板告诉我，他要失去他最好的注册护理助理（CNA）了——他说她是这栋楼的骄傲。家庭成员们都喜欢玛丽。当我走进大楼时，资深护士长弗勒里内特带我去了二楼，沿途向我介绍情况。她指着一个房间说，住在那里的那位女士拒绝被任何人从椅子移动到床上，除了玛丽。
If Marie is not here, we have to make sure that we go and tell her why Marie is not here.
如果玛丽不在，我们必须确保去告诉她为什么玛丽不在。
Why?
为什么？
Because she's used to Marie. She's used to her. And Marie treats her with respect. So she really is an exemplary CNA. I've worked with many CNAs. I know everyone. This is Marie.
因为她习惯了玛丽。她习惯了她。玛丽尊重她。所以她真的是一位模范CNA。我带过很多CNA，大家都认识。这就是玛丽。
Oh, hello.
哦，你好。
How are you doing?
你怎么样？
I've heard so much about you.
我听过太多关于你的事了。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Well--
嗯——
Oh.
噢。
--this is another Marie.
——这是另一位玛丽。
A different Marie? OK.
另一个玛丽？好吧。
Yes. This is another Marie.
是的。这是另一个玛丽。
Apparently, there are a lot of Maries in this building-- Marie Joulet, Marie Claire, Marie France. I ask Fleurinette, how much of the staff here is Haitian? And she says, oh, we all are, except for-- and she scans the floor-- her.
显然，这栋楼里有很多玛丽——玛丽·朱莱、玛丽·克莱尔、玛丽·弗朗斯。我问弗勒里内特，这里的员工有多少是海地人？她说，噢，我们都是，除了——她扫视了一下楼层——她。
She is not Haitian. But I think I see three CNAs already, and all three of them are Haitian.
她不是海地人。但我想我看到三个CNA了，而且全是海地人。
And then, a small woman in glasses, gold hoops, ponytail, and pink scrubs walks purposefully down the hall toward us.
这时，一位戴着眼镜、戴着金耳圈、扎着马尾辫、穿着粉色洗手衣的小个子女性朝我们走来。
Chana, here is your Marie.
查娜，这就是你的玛丽。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
So nice to meet you. I've heard so much about you already, before even meeting you.
很高兴见到你。在见到你之前，我已经听过太多关于你的事了。
OK. OK. I'm here a long time.
好的，好的。我在这儿很久了。
How long have you been here?
你在这儿工作多久了？
12 years.
12年了。
Do you know that you have a reputation here as being one of the best?
你知道你在这里被誉为最优秀的员工之一吗？
Yes, I know. [LAUGHS]
是的，我知道。[笑]
But Marie is not particularly interested in talking about this or dwelling on her talents. Marie's not a dweller. For a person who's a star, she's the opposite of flashy. She's focused, quiet, exceedingly polite. But I'm asking questions, and I can tell she's distracted, glancing at the rooms behind me, where her residents are.
但玛丽并不想谈论这个，也不想沉溺于自己的才华。玛丽不是那种多愁善感的人。作为明星员工，她一点也不张扬。她专注、安静，极其礼貌。但我一直在提问，看得出她有些心不在焉，时不时看向我身后的房间，那里住着她的护理对象。
I have somebody in the bathroom for now. I'm kind of--
我得先去照看洗手间里的那位。我有点——
OK. So I'll set up. OK, OK.
好的。那我就先准备一下。好的，好的。
OK. Thank you.
好的。谢谢。
Thanks.
谢谢你的到来。
Thank you for coming.
噢，我很高兴能来。
Oh, I'm so glad to be here.
从那里开始，玛丽就一直忙个不停。她邀请我跟着她，从一个护理对象到下一个——
From there, Marie is in motion. And she invites me to follow her, from one resident to the next--
我来了，妈妈。我来了。我来了。
I'm coming, mama. I'm coming. I'm coming.
——进出洗手间和布草间，在病床间穿梭，换床单时嘴里哼着福音赞美诗——
--in and out of bathrooms and linen closets, between bedsides, humming evangelical hymns to herself, as she changes sheets--
[哼唱声]
[HUMMING]
——然后清理脏物。
--and cleans up messes.
[流水声]
[WATER RUNNING]
我本以为我们要谈论玛丽生活中即将发生的巨大改变，关于这很可能是她这份工作的最后一周。但实际上，我好像正在目睹她度过最后的一周。其他的护士和CNA在观察我和我的麦克风，彼此询问：“她在干什么？她在跟踪玛丽吗？为什么？因为她工作出色吗？”然后他们也想加入谈话，补充说：“我也能告诉你玛丽工作有多出色。”
I thought we were going to talk about this huge change that was about to happen in Marie's life, about what is likely her last week on this job. But actually, it seems like I'm going to watch her do her last week on the job. And the other nurses and CNAs are watching me and my microphone and asking each other, what's she doing? She's following Marie? Why? Because she's good at her job? And then they want to talk and add on, saying, I can also tell you how good Marie is at her job.
她从不说“不”。她总是为每个人随时待命。
She never say no. She always be there for everybody.
她真的很特别。
She's just really special.
她了解他们所有的小怪癖。她在培训新人时会说：“他们喜欢在左脚穿袜子，但右脚不穿。”她记得所有那些你根本不需要记住的工作细节。她太棒了，所以——
She knows all their little quirks. And she'll be training someone and say, they like a sock on their left foot, but not on their right. And she remembers all those things that you don't have to remember to do your job. She's great, so--
你知道玛丽这周，也就是本周结束时会发生什么吗？
And do you know what's happening with Marie this week at the end of this week.
我不知道，不清楚。
I do not, no.
好的，没关系。
OK, yeah.
我尴尬地结束了谈话，之后又遇到了几次类似的情况，一点点拼凑出真相：这里没人知道玛丽生活中正在发生的大事。玛丽邀请我来，是知道我在做关于TPS人群的报道，关于她即将失去工作的事。但和她共事的同事们不知道她的工作即将结束，也不知道她是TPS身份，尽管这里大多数员工都是海地人。有些人也是TPS身份，比如玛丽，但大多数不是。一位叫南希的员工告诉我，我们给彼此空间。
I get out of the conversation awkwardly and have a couple more moments just like this where I gather, bit by bit, that nobody here knows the major thing that is happening in Marie's life. Marie has invited me here, knowing I'm doing a story about people on TPS, about her job ending. But the people she works with don't know her job is ending, or that she's on TPS, even though most people who work here are Haitian. Some of them are on TPS, like Maria's, but most aren't. A woman on staff named Nancy told me, we give each other privacy.
我们不直接问问题，因为我们不知道谁有身份，谁没有。所以我们只是作为群体交谈。
We don't ask questions directly because we don't know who have it, who doesn't have it, and things like that. So we just stay-- talk as a group.
南希说，当最高法院允许特朗普政府终止海地人的TPS时，员工们在下班时聚在一起谈论TPS终止是多么令人难过，大家有多么恐惧。她说，在那些谈话中，玛丽对其他有TPS身份的同事表现得非常有同情心。但南希显然不知道玛丽也是其中之一。
Nancy said the day that the Supreme Court allowed the Trump administration to end TPS for Haitians, the staff got together at the end of the day and talked about how sad it was that TPS was ending, how scared people were. She said Marie, in particular, was very sympathetic in those conversations toward our other coworkers who have TPS. But Nancy clearly did not know Marie is one of those coworkers.
她为别人感到难过。每个人都在谈论它，尤其是玛丽，因为她对每个人都充满关怀。
And she was feeling for everybody else. Everybody was talking about it, especially Marie, because she's very caring like that for everybody.
怎么样？
How's it going?
挺好的。
Good.
是吗？
Yeah?
我抓住了从房间出来的玛丽，把她拉到一边。
I catch Marie coming out of her room and pull her aside for a minute.
你的同事一直在问我在做什么。我说我在跟随你。似乎没人知道关于TPS的事情。你希望我不——我什么都没说。
And your coworkers have been asking what I'm doing. And I've been saying, I'm following you. And nobody seems to know about TPS and that stuff. Do you want me not-- I have not said anything.
不。
No.
所以你没有和这里的人谈过这件事？
So you haven't talked to people here about it?
没有，我不想和他们谈。
No, I don't want to talk to them about it.
好的。我可以问问为什么吗？
OK. Can I ask why?
我只是想——
I just want--
嗯。
Yeah.
[轻笑]
[CHUCKLING]
好的。
OK.
如果发生什么事，我不能来了，我会告诉他们的。但现在，不。
If something happened, I cannot come, I will tell them. But for now, nope.
是啊。如果发生了什么事，你会在那一天告诉他们吗？你是这个意思吗？
Yeah. If something happens, you would tell them on that day? Is that what you mean?
是的。
Yeah.
好的。
OK.
我不会——在12年后，我不会就这样消失。我会告诉他们的。但现在，不，我什么都不会说。他们对我一无所知。
I'm not going to-- after 12 years, I'm not going to just disappear. No, I will tell them. But for now, no, I don't tell them anything. They don't know anything about me.
后来我了解到，这种沉默是很普遍的。有太多TPS持有者在餐厅、机场、学校默默地度过每一天，深知这可能随时结束，却不告诉任何人。超过30万名海地人处于TPS身份——这是多么庞大的人群。
I learned, the more I talked to more people, that this silence is common. There were so many people on TPS moving through their work days in restaurants, airports, schools, quietly knowing it could end at any moment and not telling anyone. Over 300,000 Haitians on TPS-- that is so many people.
就移民身份而言，我认为“临时保护身份”非常奇怪。它不是工作签证，没有通往更永久身份的途径，比如绿卡。TPS没有出路。它哪儿也去不了。你可以拥有它多年、几十年，但也可能随时被终止。
As immigration statuses go, Temporary Protective Status strikes me as a very strange one. It's not an employment visa, where there can be a path to a more permanent status, like a green card. TPS offers no path. It leads nowhere. You can have it for years. You can have it for decades. It can be terminated at any time.
行政部门拥有提供TPS的自由裁量权，也拥有撤销它的权利。其他移民身份都有处理流程，有步骤，有上诉系统。TPS更像是国王的赏赐，纯粹是一个“大拇指朝上或朝下”的系统。
The executive branch has discretion to offer TPS and discretion to take it away. With other immigration statuses, there's a process. There are steps to take and a system for appeals. TPS is more like a gift from the king, just a thumbs up, thumbs down kind of system.
海地现在的局势可以说比2011年玛丽获得TPS时更加危险。但奥巴马总统当时支持海地人的TPS，而今天的特朗普总统不支持。这就像是一种基于“氛围”的移民身份。当我问玛丽如何看待TPS时，她只是耸耸肩。能说什么呢？我能做什么？她通过翻译用克里奥尔语告诉我——
Haiti is arguably more dangerous than it was in 2011, when Marie was granted TPS. But President Obama was into TPS for Haitians back then, and President Trump today is not. So it's like a vibes-based immigration status. When I asked Marie how she was thinking about TPS, she'd just shrug. What's there to say? What can I do? She told me in Creole, through an interpreter--
[讲克里奥尔语]
[SPEAKING CREOLE]
——我明白悬在头顶的危险，但我无能为力。她没有更多要说的。或许也没什么好说的。
--I understand the danger that's hanging, but there's nothing else I can do. She doesn't have a lot more to say about that. And maybe there just isn't a lot more to say.
那么，这一切将如何收场？几个月来，海地人TPS终止的具体生效时间一直不清楚。到底是哪一天？雇主们不断刷新政府网站，查看新闻，试图弄清楚何时该告诉员工他们不能再来了，以及该如何处理？
So, how was this going to go, the actual end? For weeks, it was unclear when exactly the TPS termination for Haitians would go into effect. Like, what day? And employers were constantly refreshing government websites and checking the news to try to figure out when to tell their employees they couldn't come back, and how should they do it?
玛丽的老板科林告诉我，他一直在寻找一种干扰最小、最不张扬的方式，来保护员工的隐私。他是应该直接把他们从排班表上撤下，给他们休带薪假，告诉所有人他们去度假了，然后他们就不会再回来了吗？是现在做，还是再等等？
Marie's boss, Colin, told me he was trying to figure out what was the least disruptive, least public way to do this that would protect his employees' privacy. Should he just take them off the schedule, put them on PTO, and tell everyone they're on vacation, and then they just won't come back? Should he do that now? Should he wait?
截止日期一变再变。TPS周五结束。然后看起来可能是周一。但周一傍晚，我打电话给他，似乎又不是周一了。
The deadlines kept changing. TPS was ending on Friday. Then it seemed like maybe it was Monday. But at the end of the day on Monday, I called him, and it seemed like maybe it wasn't Monday.
我不知道。我完全不知道现在发生了什么。我什么都没听到。感觉好像今天是截止日期，但我没有从任何政府来源获得确定消息。
I have no idea. I have no idea what's going on right now. I've heard nothing. It feels like, yeah, today is the date, but I'm not getting anything from a government source that says, absolutely, it's the date.
有人可以联系吗？
Is there someone to reach out to?
我不带讽刺意味的话没法回答这个问题。我的意思是，我不知道是否有这么个人。
I can't answer that question without being sarcastic. I mean, I don't know that there is somebody.
周二，我下午2:45走进疗养院。进门时我看到科林坐在入口旁的一楼办公桌前——穿着扣领衬衫，蓄着大胡子。他40岁。我告诉科林我采访了玛丽，说今天下午3点她开始上班时我会在这儿。他说——
Tuesday, I walked into the nursing home at 2:45. I saw Colin on my way into the building, sitting at his desk on the first floor by the entrance-- button-down, large beard. He's 40 years old. I tell Colin I talked to Marie and said I'd be here today for the start of her shift at 3:00. And he said--
我今天确实开了人力资源会议。我们已做出公司层面的决定，目前要将所有受TPS影响的员工从排班表中撤下。由于缺乏指导意见，我们觉得必须把他们从排班表上移除。
I did meet with HR today. And we have made a company-wide decision that at this point, we are going to take anyone affected by TPS off the schedule. The lack of guidance, we feel like we have to remove them from the schedule.
哇，好吧。那她今天上班吗？
Wow, OK. So, is she working today?
她今天上班。
She's working today. She's working today.
她知道吗？
Does she know that?
我还没和她谈。不。我在等玛丽来。我会让她先安顿好，大概4点或5点我会和她谈谈。
I have not talked to her yet. No. I'm waiting for Marie to come in. I'll let her get settled in. I'll have a conversation with her probably around 4 or 5 o'clock.
为什么不在她来的时候就告诉她？
How come you wouldn't just tell her when she gets here?
我觉得当着门抓住某人不太好。“嘿，你刚进门。”我想让她先安顿好，正常开始工作。然后等我们都有时间和空间时，再坐下来谈话。但我确实想进行面对面的交谈。
I don't think it's right to grab somebody walking through the door. Hey, you're walking through the door. So I want to let her settle and have her normal chain. And then I'll sit down and have a conversation with her when we both have time and space to do it. But I do want to have a face-to-face conversation.
与此同时，玛丽已经到了。她在楼上。她从另一扇门进来的。同事们在她准备工作时纷纷向她问好。
Meanwhile, Marie is already here. She's upstairs. She came in through a different door. Her coworkers are greeting her as she sets up.
嗨，美女。你怎么样？
Hi, beauty. How are you?
挺好的，亲爱的。
I'm OK, baby.
她穿着薰衣草色的洗手衣，戴着金银色的头巾，正在整理推车。玛丽不仅仅是随意抓一个预备好的推车。
She's in lavender scrubs and a gold and silver headwrap, arranging her cart for her shift. Marie doesn't just grab one of the pre-stocked carts.
我喜欢自己整理推车。我必须自己整理。
I like to fix my cart. I have to fix it.
你必须亲自做。
You have to do it yourself.
是啊，是啊。我会放上毛巾、尿垫、床单、病服、枕套。
Yeah, yeah. And I put towels, pad, sheet, gown, pillowcase.
突然之间，玛丽所做的一切都成了最后一次，她数着毯子，整齐地叠在中层架子上。床单、尿布和护肤霜放在顶层，她推着推车前往101房间，早班人员正准备下班——
All of a sudden, everything Marie is doing becomes the last time she will do it, counting the blankets and stacking them neatly on the middle shelf. Fitted sheets, diapers, and cream go on the top shelf, pushing her cart to room 101 as the morning shift heads out--
好的。
OK.
再见，阿尔伯特。再见，玛丽。
Bye, Albert. Bye, Marie.
再见，玛丽。明天见。
Bye, Marie. See you tomorrow.
好的，明天见。开车小心。
All right, see you tomorrow. Drive safe home.
谢谢。
Thank you.
——查看每位住户。
--checking on each resident.
嗨，玛丽。
Hi, Marie.
嗨，你好吗？
Hi, how are you?
昨天没看到你。
I didn't see you yesterday.
那天是我休息日。
It was my day off.
噢？
Oh?
是啊。
Yeah.
我喜欢你的银色饰品。
I like your silver.
谢谢。
Thank you.
你得小心太阳。
You got to watch out-- the sun.
是啊。
Yeah.
戴上太阳镜。
Put the sunglasses on.
是啊。
Yeah.
隔壁100号房间挤满了访客。玛丽安静地绕过家属，整理床单，擦拭表面，倒满水杯。这份工作是一系列无穷无尽的小动作。它细致，工作距离近且艰难。玛丽既勤劳又隐形。
Next door, room 100, is full of visitors. Marie maneuvers quietly around the family, arranging sheets, wiping surfaces, filling water cups. This job is a series of endless small gestures. It's delicate. It's close, difficult work. Marie is both productive and invisible.
[哼唱声]
[HUMMING]
她准备好洗澡水，然后轻轻引导家属如何在她给94岁的母亲洗澡和换衣服时提供帮助。
She preps the bath and then gently guides the family on how they can be helpful as she washes and changes their 94-year-old mother.
不，不是那个。
No, not that.
[听不清]
[INAUDIBLE]
妈妈，妈妈。
Mama, Mama.
妈妈，冷静点。
Mama, tranquila.
妈妈，我们只是在帮你，好吗？
Mama, we're just helping you, OK?
玛丽正走出100号房间，手臂里抱着脏床单，科林进入了她所在的走廊。他朝她走去——
Marie is on her way out of room 100, arms full of dirty linens, when Colin enters the hallway to her unit. He walks toward her--
嘿，玛丽。
Hey, Marie.
是。你怎么样？
Yeah. How are you?
你怎么样？
How are you?
很好。
Good.
——但随后又继续往前走了。他直接走过了她。看起来他临时决定现在不是谈话的时候。玛丽推着装满脏床单的推车去了下一个房间，来到一位同事身边小声问她，问另一个CNA今天去哪了。玛丽说：“她请假了吗？”同事说：“是的，我想是因为TPS那件事。他们终止了。”
--but then keeps going. He walks right by her. It looks like he made a last-minute calculation that this is not the time. Marie rolls a cart of soiled linens to the next room, pulls up next to a coworker and whispers to her, asks her where another CNA is today. Marie says, did she call out? That coworker says, yes, I think it's about the TPS thing. They closed it.
嗯，他们终止了。是的。
Mm-hmm, they closed it. Yes.
玛丽说：“我也听说了。”这时呼叫铃亮了。她又朝走廊深处走去。
Marie says, that's what I heard. Then a call button lights up. She heads toward it, back down the hall.
你还好吗？你需要更换吗？好的。
You OK? You need to be changed? OK.
接着她在出房间的路上被我拦住了。我问：“你和科林谈过吗？”
Then she's on her way out of that room, and I interrupt. And I ask, have you checked in with Colin?
他告诉我，如果有事发生他会叫我。他刚才过来时看见我了，但我们没谈。
He told me, anything happen, he will call me. He saw me when he came here earlier, but we did not talk.
好的。你没问吗？你什么都没问他？
OK. And you haven't asked? You haven't asked him anything?
不，不，不。我不想让他尴尬。
No, no, no. I don't want to embarrass him.
为什么对他来说会尴尬？
Why would it be embarrassing for him?
因为他不想让我走。
Because he doesn't like me to leave.
他不想让你走？
He doesn't want you to leave?
是啊。
Yeah.
是啊。他看到我离开不会高兴的。我不会问他任何事。
Yeah. He's not happy to see me leave. I'm not going to ask him anything.
在我们旁边，走廊里一个穿着亮黄色袜子的男人一直用长腿拖着轮椅来回走动，嘴里说着：“我不知道，我不知道，我不知道。”一位护士靠近玛丽说：“你能帮我朋友插尿管吗？”
Next to us, a man in the hallway with bright yellow socks has been using his long legs to drag his wheelchair back and forth, saying, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know. And a nurse leans close to Marie and says, could you help my friend with the catheter?
插尿管？
For the catheter?
是的。
Yeah.
好的。过来，过来，老人家。
Yeah. Come. Come, papa.
科林又走过来，扫视了一下房间，但玛丽在洗手间。
Colin comes by again, glances in the rooms, but Marie is in the bathroom.
噢，噢，把裤子拉下来。[哼唱声]
Oh, oh, pull the pants down. [HUMMING]
她排干了导尿袋。
She empties the catheter.
[液体泼溅声]
[LIQUID SPLASHING]
[哼唱声]
[HUMMING]
[流水声]
[WATER RUNNING]
就在这时，科林绕了一圈。玛丽把那个男人推回走廊，科林看到她从房间出来，但穿黄袜子的男人情绪激动，指着自己的裤子。他也要玛丽帮他换裤子。
As this is happening, Colin does a lap. Marie pushes the man back into the hallway, and Colin spots her coming out of the room, but the man with the yellow socks is agitated and pointing at his pants. He wants Marie to change his pants, too.
像这样。不。
Like this. No.
噢，你还要换另一条裤子？过来。[哼唱声]
Oh, you want, too, another pants? Come. [HUMMING]
所以他们回到了房间。
So they're back into the room.
好的，站起来，老人家。
OK, stand up, papa.
[呻吟声]
[GROANING]
慢慢来。不，不。不要滑倒。
Take your time. No, no. Don't slide.
[呻吟声]
[GROANS]
科林又回到楼下去了。
Colin disappears back downstairs.
一个人如何结束12年的职业生涯而不被打断，没有混乱，没有引起任何人的注意？科林在寻找一个安静处理的时机，但没有。这是个极其忙碌且不可或缺的人。CNA在全国范围内都很难招到和留住。人们从事这份工作的平均时间只有两年。
How do you end a 12-year career without interrupting, without disruption, without anyone noticing? Colin is looking for an opening to do this quietly, but there is not one. This is a person who is busy and needed. CNAs are hard to find and hard to keep all over the country. The average time people stay in these jobs is two years.
玛丽就在这里。她的老板不想让她走。她也不想走。他不想让她尴尬，她也不想让他尴尬。这与过去一年半里我们看到的驱逐场面不同。没有那种在公共场合被强行拖走，在戏剧性甚至有时暴力的视频中被带走的人。这是一场在全国各处工作场所上演的静默剧，是所有人能做到的最安静的结局。
And here's Marie. Her boss doesn't want her to leave. And she doesn't want to leave. He doesn't want to embarrass her. And she doesn't want to embarrass him. This is not the version of removing people that we've seen so much of in the last year and a half. It's not people grabbed in public, pulled out of cars in dramatic, sometimes violent, videos. This is a silent play being performed in workplaces across the country, the quietest ending everyone involved can possibly pull off.
下午5:30，当晚餐托盘到达时，玛丽在住户间穿梭，整理床头柜，分发餐盘。一位访客对她说：“我们要走了。我奶奶一个人在这儿。多照看下。”
By 5:30 PM, when the dinner trays arrive, Marie is moving between residents, arranging bedside tables, delivering food trays. A visitor tells her, we're going to head out now. My grandma's alone. Keep an eye.
你们要走了？
You're leaving?
是的。
Yeah.
她没事的。
She's OK.
是的。
Yeah.
她会独自待着。
She'll be here by herself.
好的。
OK.
好的，谢谢。
All right. Thank you.
好的，没问题。我会照顾的。
OK, no problem. I will take care.
好的。
OK.
好的，再见。
OK, bye.
玛丽安慰了她，然后发现一个男人来陪妻子吃晚饭。玛丽找了一把折叠椅，一声不吭地放在他身后，然后继续走。与此同时，科林现在在二楼，他没走。我能隐约听到他在护士站另一侧，好像在和某个家伙谈论打印机。
Marie reassures her, then spots a man who's come to have dinner with his wife. Marie finds a folding chair, places it behind him without saying anything, and keeps walking. Meanwhile, Colin is on the second floor now, and he's not leaving. I can hear him faintly somewhere on the other side of the nurses' station, talking to some guy about printers, I think.
下午6:00，科林直接走到玛丽所在的单元，扫视了一下四周。他看到她端着空的晚餐托盘。他轻声说：“嘿，玛丽，有空吗？”“当然，”她说。她放下托盘，跟他走下走廊。他们和一个翻译一起进了一个房间。过程持续了七分钟。科林不想让我录音。当玛丽出来时，我没有再开启录音。
At 6:00 PM, Colin just walks straight to Marie's unit and scans the area. He sees her carrying empty dinner trays. He says quietly, hey, Marie, you got a minute? Sure, she says. She places the trays down and follows him down the hall. They go into a room with an interpreter. It takes seven minutes. Colin doesn't want me to record. And when Marie comes out, I don't turn the recorder back on.
她对我说了：“他们暂时把我从排班表上撤下来了，直到他有更多信息。这可能就是结局了。”我告诉她我很抱歉。她说：“他们说我现在可以回家，或者完成剩下的班次。取决于我。我有选择权。”然后玛丽做了一件我还没见她做过的事。她谈到了自己在这份工作上做得多好。她说：“2014年我刚开始工作时，工资很低。每年他们都看到我的工作方式和成果。每年他们都给我加薪。现在，我不告诉你我赚多少钱，但比我刚开始时翻了一倍。”
She says to me, well, they're taking me off the schedule for now, until he has more information. This is maybe the end. I tell her I'm sorry. She says, they said I can go home now or finish my shift. It's up to me. I have the choice. And then Marie does something I have not yet seen her do. She talks about how good she is at this job. She says, when I started here in 2014, my salary was very low. Every year, they saw the way I'm working and the work I've done. And every year, they gave me more. Right now, I won't tell you how much I make, but it's double where I started.
我告诉她，我相信你是应得的。她哽咽着说：“谢谢。”然后她说，她决定完成剩下的班次，她得回去工作了。她站起来，沿着走廊走回去。
I tell her, I'm sure you deserve it. She gets choked up and says, thank you. Then, she says, she's decided to finish her shift, and she should get back to it. She stands up and walks back down the hall.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人。接下来，一个喜剧演员走进一家酒吧，带出来一个医学之谜。稍后回来，芝加哥公共广播，节目继续。
Chana Joffe-Walt is a producer on our show. Coming up, a comedian walks into a bar and walks out with a medical mystery. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
这里是《美国生活》。我是托宾·洛，代班伊拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《标签制造机！》全部关于标签的力量。我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“可能诊断我”。
It's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "Label Maker!" a show all about the power of labels. We're at Act Two of our show. Act 2, "Diagnose Me, Maybe."
我最近一直思考标签，原因就是我们要讲的下一个故事。故事关于珍妮特·麦克纳马拉，一位非常有趣的喜剧演员，15年前她刚出道时发生了件奇怪的事。事情是这样的，那天晚上，她在波士顿的一家喜剧俱乐部表演，那是她的故乡——我觉得所有爱尔兰裔天主教徒都一样。总之，她下台后去了休息室，俱乐部老板拦住了她。
So the whole reason I've been thinking about labels lately is because of this next story we're doing today. It's about Janet McNamara, a very funny comedian who had this odd thing happen to her 15 years ago when she was first getting started. What happened was, this one night, she's performing at a comedy club in Boston, where she's proudly from-- I think all Irish Catholics are. Anyway, she gets off stage, goes to the green room, when the owner of the club stops her.
他只是出于好奇问：“当你抬头看天空，眼珠转动时那是什么？”我确实有这个习惯。我的记忆力很差，所以当我记不起词或不知道接下来要说什么时，我会抬头看。我说：“那是我思考时的习惯。”他说：“你有没有做过自闭症测试？”我说：“不，我从来没考虑过自己是自闭症患者。”字面上讲，从来没人对我提过。
He just kind of said, out of curiosity, what's that thing when you look up in the air, and you dart your eyes? And I do this thing. I have really bad memory recall. So I look up in the air a lot when I can't think of a word or I can't think of what I'm going to say next. And I said, that's what I do when I'm thinking. And he said, have you ever been tested for autism? And I said, no, I've never considered that I'm autistic before. Literally, nobody has ever said it to me before.
那家喜剧俱乐部在哪？
And where was this comedy club?
叫“迪克·多尔蒂喜剧金库”。而这位迪克·多尔蒂，是第一个问我是不是自闭症患者的人。
It was called Dick Doherty's Comedy Vault. And this guy, Dick Doherty, he's the first person who asked me if I was autistic.
噢，那是俱乐部的老板。
Oh, it was the namesake of the club.
是的。他以自己的名字命名俱乐部。没错。
Yeah. He named a club after himself. Yes, correct.
明白了。
Gotcha.
珍妮特没当回事，觉得这挺滑稽。她是喜剧演员，所以开始在波士顿到处登台，讲述这家伙没头没脑问她这个问题的事。观众笑了。但演出结束后，人们会走到她面前说：“嘿——”
Janet brushed it off, thought it was sort of funny. And she is a comedian, so she started getting on stage around Boston, telling the story about this guy asking this question out of nowhere. It got laughs. But also, after the show, people would come up to her and say, hey--
“我是自闭症患者。只是告诉你一声，你也是。”
I'm autistic. Just to let you know, you're also autistic.
他们说得那么直接？
They'd say it that bluntly?
是的。
Yeah.
那你什么感觉？你怎么回应？
And how would that feel? How would you react?
我会说：“我不觉得我是。”
I would say, I don't think I am.
珍妮特说，作为90年代成长的孩子，她做过很多次学习障碍、焦虑症的测试。从来没有医疗专业人士提到过“自闭症”这个词。当她和家人、朋友聊起时，他们会说：“是啊，你修剪头发的速度慢得有点怪，这样就没人能说‘嘿，你剪头发了’。”但主要是，他们说——
Janet says, as a kid growing up in the '90s, she'd been tested many times for learning disabilities, for anxiety. Never once did any of those medical professionals say the word "autistic." When she talked about it with her family, her friends, they'd say, yeah, it's a little weird that you get your hair cut in slow increments, so no one says, hey, you got a haircut. But mainly, they said--
“你不是自闭症。你只是个波士顿人。”
You're not autistic. You're from Boston.
[笑声]
[LAUGHS]
但人们在演出后不断对她说这件事，确实引起了她的好奇。她想，可能没什么，但问问精神科医生觉得有没有可能，又有什么损失呢？下面是珍妮特在台上谈论这导致的结果。
But the fact that people kept saying it to her after shows, it raised a curiosity. She thought, it's probably nothing, but what's the harm in asking my psychiatrist if he thinks it's possible? Here's Janet talking on stage about what this all led to.
那是阿斯伯格综合征还存在的时候。现在已经没有了。现在叫“自闭症谱系”。他们去掉了这个名字。他是个纳粹。阿斯伯格是个纳粹。是啊，多读读书吧。
It was when Asperger's was still a thing. It's not a thing anymore. Now, they call it the autism spectrum. They unnamed it. He was a Nazi. Asperger's was a Nazi. Yeah, read a book.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我记得我参加了测试，那家伙从笔记本里抬起头说：“嗯，阿斯伯格患者的智商通常高于平均水平，所以——”
I remember I took the test, and the guy, he just looked up from his notebook and he goes, well, people with Asperger's generally have above average IQs, so--
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
“我不够聪明，当不了轻度自闭症患者——”
I'm not smart enough to be mildly autistic--
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
——这就是那个医生告诉我的。
--is what that doctor told me.
这同样是她的精神科医生。珍妮特决定随它去，部分原因是那是2010年代。成年人进行自闭症测试的想法还没像现在这样普及。她想，行吧，就是这样。没必要一直去争取那个测试。所以多年来，自闭症只是舞台上的一个搞笑梗，她脱口秀的一部分。但在舞台下，珍妮特有一份日常工作。而那里的事情却变得一点也不好笑。
This, again, was her actual psychiatrist. Janet decided to let it go, partly because this was back in the 2010s. And the idea of an adult getting tested for autism, it just wasn't in the air the same way it is now. She thought, OK, that's it. No need to keep pushing for a test. So for years, autism was just a funny bit on stage, part of her standup. But offstage, Janet had a day job. And what was happening there would turn out to be not so funny.
舞台下，珍妮特找到了她认为完美的工作。她是一名会计，大学毕业后从水管公司的簿记员做起。她喜欢会计，因为她本质上是个问题解决者。查看账簿，Excel表格，指出错误。老板很喜欢她，因为珍妮特工作高效——没有闲聊，没有废话。
Offstage, Janet had found what she thought was the perfect job. She was an accountant, worked her way into it after being a bookkeeper for a plumbing company right out of college. She liked accounting because she was essentially a problem-solver. Looked at ledgers, Excel spreadsheets, pointed out where there were errors. And her boss loved her because Janet got her job done quickly and efficiently-- no small talk, no bullshit.
她甚至定期加薪。直到有一天，她来了一位新老板，一位喜欢闲聊、想要更多小组会议、更多同事社交的老板。起初，这位新老板要求和珍妮特一对一沟通，以便互相了解。
She even got raises regularly. That is, until one day, she got a new boss, one who liked small talk, wanted more group meetings, more socializing amongst coworkers. Early on, this new boss asked Janet to meet one-on-one so they could get to know each other.
她说：“我有两个孩子。我喜欢徒步。”然后她转过身，向我展示她的两个孩子——她转过身，拿起一张她两个孩子的框照片，递给我。我只是说：“我从这里就能看到。”当我走进她办公室时，我就看到了她孩子的照片。我走进她办公室时立刻就知道，她有两个孩子。他们大概12岁。男孩比女孩大。好的，酷。我了解所有这些信息。
And she said, I have two kids. I enjoy hiking. And then she turned around and showed me her two kids with a-- she showed me a-- she turned around and picked up a framed picture of her two kids and went to hand it to me. And I just said, I could see that from here. When I walked into her office, I saw the pictures of her kids. I immediately knew, when I walked into her office, she has two kids. They're about 12 years old. The boy's older than the girl. OK, cool. I know all this information.
锁定了。我知道了。我懂了。
Clocked. I know this. I got it.
然后她又口头告诉我，还把照片递给我，我就想：“我早就知道了。为什么我们要谈这个？你有一张照片。你桌上有照片的原因就是为了不让人问你有没有孩子。”
And then she just tells me verbally and then hands me the picture, and I'm like, I already know this. Why are we talking about this? You have a picture. That's why you have a picture on your desk, is so that people don't start asking if you have kids because there's a picture on your desk.
珍妮特在表演中谈到了她在工作场所的事情是如何变质的。
Janet talks in her act about how things started to sour for her in the workplace.
我当时在工作上很艰难。在工作上艰难是因为我的性格。
I was having a hard time at work at the time. I was having a hard time at work because of my personality.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
是啊，他们说我在工作时很粗鲁。他们说我语气不好。他们说我邮件里的语气不好。我就想，邮件怎么会有语气不好？我又没在唱歌。
Yeah, they said I was rude at work. They said I had bad tone. They said I had bad tone in my emails. I was like, how could you have bad tone in an email? I wasn't singing.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我说：“你们这些人需要放松。”在绩效改进计划期间，我告诉老板放松点。
I was like, you people need to relax. I told my boss to relax during a performance improvement plan.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
即使她在台上拿这开玩笑，事情却是严肃的。看起来她可能会丢掉工作。最困难的是，感觉他们并不是要求她改进工作。那部分她一直做得很好。感觉他们是要求她改变性格，改变她根本的生存方式。这又要怎么修复呢？
And even though she joked about it on stage, it was serious. Seemed like she might lose her job. And what made it so difficult was that it felt like she wasn't being asked to improve her work. She was always good at that part. It was like she was being asked to change her personality, her fundamental way of being, which, how do you even go about fixing that?
她对此变得非常焦虑和紧张。她休了一段时间的病假，希望能找到解决方案。然后她去咨询医生那可能会是什么样子，比如一个远离办公室嘈杂声的私人办公桌，有权不参加那些大型聚会。她问医生能否帮她提出这些住宿要求。他说：“这些听起来像是如果你是自闭症患者才会提出的要求——又是那个标签。”珍妮特决定再次寻求诊断，这次是因为需求已经非常紧迫。
She became so anxious and stressed about it. She took medical leave for a while, hoping she could figure out a solution. And then she went to talk to a doctor about what that might look like, like a more private desk away from the chatter of the office, the ability to sit out those meetings with large groups of people. She asked the doctor if he could help her ask for these accommodations. And he said, those sound like what you'd ask for if you were autistic-- again, that label. Janet decided to look into a diagnosis again, this time because the need had become dire.
珍妮特去参加了她第一次正式的自闭症测试，这次是真正的测试。顺便说一句，自闭症测试很复杂，因为没有血液测试。相反，通常会有多次会话，测试者观察社交互动、感官问题、重复行为或固定的兴趣。然后他们综合所有这些来做出诊断，这就是珍妮特这次经历的。
Janet goes for her first official autism test, which, this time, was an actual real deal test. Testing for autism, by the way, is complex because there's no blood test. Instead, there are usually multiple sessions during which the tester is looking at social interactions, sensory issues, repetitive behaviors, or fixated interests. And then they take all of this into account to assign a diagnosis, which is what Janet went through this time.
不知道有没有人做过这个。它是一整套东西。像是三天的过程。你看着人们的照片，他们会问，他们看起来开心还是难过？他们会发调查问卷。我表现得很完美。我一切都做得完美，但我没拿到诊断。就像我说的，我没拿到。他知道我也想要那个诊断。
I don't know if anybody's ever had one. It's like this whole thing. It's like a three-day thing. You look at pictures of people, and they're like, they look happy, they look sad. And they send surveys. And I was perfect. I had everything perfect, and I didn't get the diagnosis. Like I said, I didn't get it. And he knew I wanted it, too.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我没拿到。我会告诉你发生了什么。最后，那家伙回来，直直地盯着我的眼睛，我可不喜欢。
I didn't get it. And I'll tell you what happens. At the end of the day, the guy, he just came back, and he just looked at me right in the eye, which I did not care for.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我发誓，他直直地盯着我的眼睛说：“你太接近了。”
I swear, he just looks at me right in the eye, and he goes, you are so close.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我对天发誓，他说：“你太接近了。只是还没完全符合所有标准。”根据他的说法，我不是自闭症的唯一原因是我衬衫上的标签不困扰我。是啊，我没有感官问题。我气坏了。我都准备好回工作岗位说：“嘿，我不需要看着你。我不是粗鲁，我是不理解。结果证明我只是粗鲁。”
I swear to god, he goes, you're so close. You just didn't quite hit all the criteria. And the criteria I didn't hit, the only reason why I'm not autistic, according to him, is because the tags on my shirts don't bother me. Yeah, I don't have sensory issues. I was pissed. I was all ready to go back to work and be like, hey, I don't have to look at you. It's not that I'm rude. It's that I don't understand. It turns out I'm just rude.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
你能看出我很粗鲁，因为衬衫上的标签不困扰我。这就是粗鲁和自闭症之间的区别。
You could tell that I'm rude because the tags on my shirts don't bother me. And that's the difference between rude and autistic.
确实感觉——感觉我别无选择，只能改变。感觉我别无选择，只能开始玩那个游戏，也就是聊天气、跟人打招呼。我也确实开始记同事孩子的名字了。
It definitely felt-- it felt like I had no choice but to change. And it felt like I had no choice but to start playing the game, which is talking about the weather and saying hi to people. And I did start learning people's kids names.
你在那份工作上坚持了多久？
How long do you feel like you were able to keep that up at that job specifically?
噢，也就三个月。我的大脑就是没法——这太难描述了。可能这就是痴呆症的感觉，你知道这不是什么难事，但你的大脑就是做不到。我就是无法运作。
Oh, like three months. My brain just wasn't-- it's so hard to describe. It's probably what dementia feels like, in that you know this isn't hard, but your brain just can't do it. I just couldn't function.
此后，珍妮特辗转于几份公司工作。她说她做得不错，但很快就遇到瓶颈，因为社交互动的要求增加了。她不得不辞职或面临被解雇。
Janet cycled through several corporate jobs after that. She said she'd do well, but then hit a wall, as the demands of interacting and socializing would increase. She'd have to quit or face being fired.
这就是珍妮特过去十年陷入的循环，试图避免日常生活中让她不舒服的情况。但当它们真的发生时，她又在台上谈论它们，用它们来换取笑声，谈论她是如何还是拿不到该死的诊断的。所以她一直硬撑着，直到最近，她有了一次经历，彻底改变了她的想法。她带一个孩子去电影院，她很熟悉的孩子。电影院里，这孩子开始跟她拥抱，小孩子经常那样。
That's the cycle Janet's been in for the last decade, trying to avoid situations in everyday life that would make her uncomfortable, but then when they do happen, talking about them on stage for laughs and how she still can't get a fucking diagnosis. So she's just kind of been toughing it out, until recently, when she had an experience that flipped her thinking about everything. She took a kid to the movies, kid she was babysitting, a kid she knew well. And at the movies, this kid started to cuddle with her, as little kids do.
我对此感到非常不舒服，她抚摸我的手臂。但我知道那是个小孩子，你不能告诉小孩——我知道这是她表达爱意的方式。我感觉自己卡住了。我哭了。
And it was so uncomfortable to me that she was stroking my arm. But I also understood that it was a little kid and that you can't just tell a little kid to-- I understood that it was, like, her way of showing affection. And I just felt so stuck. And I started crying.
因为你得处理它。这是你要解决的问题。
Because you had to deal with it. It was your problem to deal with.
我觉得我是成年人。我得接受。
I felt like I'm the adult. I just need to take this.
珍妮特从不适转为纯粹对自己生气。
Janet went from discomfort to just being flat-out mad at herself.
[抽泣声] 你作为一个人的感觉有多糟糕，如果你只想对小孩说：“别碰我。别抱我。别对我示爱。”作为一个不喜欢拥抱小孩，并觉得这是一种压倒性经历的人，从人类层面来说感觉并不好。
[SNIFFLING] How awful are you as a person if you just want to say to a little kid, like, stop touching me. Stop cuddling with me. Stop showing me affection. It just doesn't feel good on a human level as a person to not want to cuddle with a little kid, and for that to be an overwhelming experience.
她把这一切告诉了现在的治疗师，治疗师说：“我觉得我们应该重新进行诊断。我觉得这对你很合适，之前的测试者搞错了。”珍妮特准备不再责怪自己，于是同意了。
She told all this to her current therapist, and her therapist said to her, I think we should revisit getting a diagnosis. I think it's right for you, and the other testers got it wrong. Janet was ready to stop blaming herself, so she agreed.
这很大程度上是一种“也许我没问题。也许我的大脑只是接线方式不同。也许我需要不再自我攻击。”
It was very much a, maybe there's nothing wrong with me. Maybe my brain is just wired different. And maybe I need to not beat myself up.
那就是我采访珍妮特的时候，她再次尝试获得诊断。我和她谈话时，就在她快要知道结果之前。结果终于出来时，她正站在一家酒吧外面。晚上11点。她打开了一份带报告的电子邮件。然后，第二天晚上，她走上缅因州波特兰的舞台，发布了这个消息。
And that's when I interviewed Janet, when she was trying yet again to get a diagnosis. When I talked to her, it was right before she was about to find out her results. When they did finally come in, she was standing outside a bar. It was 11:00 PM. She opened an email with a report. And then, the next night, she went on stage in Portland, Maine, and dropped the news.
那位女士说：“我不清楚发生了什么，但你绝对是自闭症。”
And the lady was like, I don't know what's going on, but you're definitely autistic.
[笑声，欢呼声]
[LAUGHTER, CHEERING]
她说：“你是自闭症，因为你对人感兴趣。你只是对无聊的事情不感兴趣。你对那些拼图拼不对的无聊人也不感兴趣。”
She was like, you're autistic because you are interested in people. And you're just not interested in things that are boring. And you're not interested in boring people who don't do puzzles correctly.
[欢呼声]
[CHEERING]
她说我的性格刻板。我很刻板。我说：“我不刻板。我只是大多数时候是对的。”
And she said I have a rigid personality. I'm rigid. And I said, I'm not rigid. I'm just, most of the time, right.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
我们讨论了治疗师最让我讨厌的话，有时候治疗师会说：“嘿，两件事可以同时为真。”我会说：“是啊，我同意，两件事可以同时为真。但在这种情况下，只有一件事是真的。”
And we talked about how my least favorite thing my therapist says is sometimes my therapist will be like, hey, two things can be true. And I'll be like, yeah, I agree, two things could be true. But in this case, one thing is true.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
下次见她时，她告诉我她对此感到很激动，但不是我想的那种原因。她告诉我最近在上一门课时与一位女性的互动经历。
The next time I see her, she tells me she's pretty stoked about it, but not for the reason I thought. She tells me about a recent experience interacting with a woman in a class she's taking.
我每天都坐特定的座位。我走进去，她坐在我的座位上。她对我说：“我坐在你的座位上。你要我让开吗？”我说：“不用，没关系。我坐这儿就行。”她说：“你确定吗？”我们来回推拉。我其实说：“实际上，我真的想坐那个位置。你能让开吗？”她让开了。她一点也不生气。她对此完全没问题。
I sit in a specific seat every day. And I walked in, and she was sitting in my seat. And she said to me, I'm sitting in your seat. Do you want me to move? And I said, no, it's OK. I'll sit over here. And she was like, are you sure? And we had this back and forth. And I actually said, actually, I really want to sit in that seat. Can you move? And she moved. And she wasn't upset at all. She was perfectly fine with it.
我从未感觉到如此被看见，有人坐在我的位置上，她们看到了我的脸，看到了我的不安。她们没有把它看作一种控制欲，或者是觉得我——她们没把它当成个人针对。这感觉非常好。是的，她没可能知道我是自闭症。只是我的表达方式，我表达得很理解。
And I've just never felt that seen before, where somebody's sitting in my seat, they saw my face, they saw that I was distressed. They didn't see it as a control thing or like I'm taking it-- they didn't take it personally that I was like, you're in my seat. It felt very good. Yeah, and there's no way she knew I was autistic. There was just something about the way I approached it, which is that I understood.
我想六个月前，我会说：“她真是个混蛋。她坐在我的座位上。她有什么毛病？为什么要坐我的位置？”我会把它当成个人针对，像她在整我，或者她在通过坐我的座位来捣乱。而不是知道这确实是我特别敏感的事情，我就是想坐在同一个地方。所以，是的。
I think six months ago, I would have said, she's an asshole. She's sitting in my seat. What's wrong with her? Why would she sit in my seat? I would have taken it personally, like she was fucking with me, or she was messing with me by sitting in my seat, as opposed to knowing that it's something that I'm specifically sensitive about, that I want to sit in the same place. So, yeah.
这似乎带出了很多你的情绪，在那种——
It seems like it brings up a lot of emotion for you, where it's--
是啊，这很奇怪。这就像一种不同的被看见的方式，甚至不用告诉别人诊断。感觉有些东西变了。我不知道我以什么不同的方式接近人，让他们没有把我的行为视为对他们的影响。这太棒了。我不知道它会如此不同。我没意识到你甚至不需要告诉人们。我接近人的方式变了。
Yeah, it's weird. It's like a different way of feeling seen, even without telling people about the diagnosis. And there's something different. I don't know exactly how I'm approaching people differently that they're not taking it personally that their behavior is affecting me. It's great. I had no idea that it would be so different. And I didn't realize that you don't even have to tell people. The way I'm approaching people is different.
确实。当我们进行最后一次采访时，我们在等摄影棚准备好，她相当直白地说：“如果我们等待时不做闲聊，我也没问题。”我理解了。所以我们在非常舒适的沉默中坐着。
It's true. When we sat down for this last interview, we were waiting for the studio to be set up, and she said, I'm fine if we don't make small talk while we wait, pretty matter-of-factly. And I understood. So we sat there in a very comfortable silence.
珍妮特·麦克纳马拉是位喜剧演员。你可以在YouTube上观看她的完整特辑《Not Smart Enough》。
Janet McNamara is a comedian. You can watch her full special, Not Smart Enough, on YouTube.
第三幕，“最后的描述”。归根结底，标签只是我们指出我们在他人身上发现的卓越之处的方式。这是作家阿尔弗雷德·荣格·李的论点。他一直在思考我们如何看待彼此，尤其是在他试图描述一个与他非常亲近的人时。下面是阿尔弗雷德。
Act 3, "The Last Description." When you get down to it, labels are just our way of pointing out what we think is remarkable about other people. That's writer Alfred Jung Lee's argument. He's been thinking a lot about what we notice in each other, especially as he tries to describe someone very close to him. Here's Alfred.
阿尔弗雷德·李·荣格：（主持人）不久前，我在一本杂志的个人资料中读到对一个人的描述，引用：“有一把巨大的白胡子，波浪状的灰发刘海，以及浓密的浓眉。”文章附有一张此人的照片。当我看着它时，我赞叹描述的效率。它没有说那个人有两只胳膊和一个鼻子。这些细节是被预设的。
(HOST) ALFRED LEE JUNG: Not long ago, I was reading in a magazine profile a description of a person who, quote, "has a prodigious white beard, wavy gray bangs, and dark beetling eyebrows." A photo of the person was included. And as I looked, I admired the efficiency of the description. It did not say that the man had two arms and a nose. These details were assumed.
反思这一点，我意识到当一个人描述某人时，描述的也是那个人如何背离常态，是什么让他们与众不同。最近，一个我从未见过的人本应在美中地区的一个机场接我，我提供了自己简洁的描述——“带了太多行李的亚洲人”，我发了短信。
Reflecting on this, it occurred to me that when one describes a person, one is also describing how that person deviates from the norm, what makes them different from everyone else. Recently, someone I'd never met was supposed to pick me up from an airport in the Midwest, and I offered a succinct description of myself-- Asian guy with too much luggage, I texted.
我走出机场，拖着两个手提箱、一个登机箱和一个背包。我听到一个陌生人在喊我的名字。我在还没到路边之前就被认出来了。描述吸引了对事物的不同之处的关注。“带太多行李的亚洲人”在锡达拉皮兹是很好的描述，在首尔就没那么好了。对最不同之处的关注越多，描述就越好。
I walked out of the airport, towing two suitcases, a carry-on, and a backpack. I heard a stranger shout my name. I was recognized before I'd even made it to the curb. Description draws attention to what is different about a thing. "Asian guy with too much luggage" is a good description in Cedar Rapids, less so in Seoul. The greater the focus on what is most different, the better the description.
在我参加的一个配偶离世支持小组里，人们经常描述他们死去的配偶。描述通常遵循一个公式。变点包括工作。死去的配偶是会计、商店经理、医护人员。个性上，他们“固执”或“爱开玩笑”。有一位女士喜欢摩托车，一位男士曾是那些非亲生孩子的慈父。有时我们会分享照片。
In an online support group I attended for spousal loss, people often described their dead spouses. The descriptions usually followed a formula. The points of variation included their job. The dead spouse was an accountant, a store manager, a health care worker. In personality, they were "stubborn" or "loved to joke." There was a woman who had liked motorcycles, a man who had been a tender father to kids who were not biologically his own. Sometimes we shared pictures.
即使我看着照片听着描述，我仍然难以理解他们曾经活着。当有人描述配偶“固执”时，我理解为他们的配偶比普通人更固执。但我不太确定这真正说了什么。大部分描述都是未言明的。
Even as I looked at the pictures and listened to the descriptions, I found it hard to understand that they were once alive. When someone described their spouse as "stubborn," I took it to mean their spouse had been more stubborn than the average person. But I wasn't sure what this really said. Most of a description goes unsaid.
最近，我的现实在不知不觉中改变了，我一直努力描述它。我父亲前几天从韩国给我打电话，给了我一次尝试的机会。我描述了我在美中新家乡的天气，就是那个我在机场被接走的地方，说那一刻是70多度，在下午晚些时候，我离校园有10分钟路程，我在那里决定回学校读写作课程，城市是丘陵的而不是平坦的。
Lately, my reality has transformed without my noticing, and I have been struggling to describe it. My father called me the other day from Korea, and it gave me a chance to try. I described the weather in my new hometown in the Midwest, the one where I'd been picked up at the airport, saying that it was in the 70s at the moment, late in the afternoon, that I was 10 minutes from campus, where I decided to go back to school for a writing program, and that the city was hilly and not flat.
他询问我的新朋友和同学，我告诉了他我告诉所有人的话——20多岁到30多岁，每个人看起来都聪明又友好。我告诉他我的单身公寓，房间足够大，采光很好，关于我从公寓能步行去的地方。
He asked about my new friends and classmates, and I told him what I've been telling everyone-- mid 20s to late 30s, everyone seemingly smart and nice. I told him about my studio apartment, that there was enough room, that it got good light, about the places I could walk to from the apartment.
但我们的谈话中还有别的东西悬着，另一张没有被描述的图片。如果事情按计划进行，我的生活会是什么样，以及这个远在我想象之外的当前情况，与那个计划可能不同或相同，这也可能影响我是否安好，从而影响父亲是否需要担心。这正是我们绕着谈论的第二张照片，那个另一个生命，以及我目前的生活在多大程度上偏离了它，也是我们谈话的主题。
But there was something else hovering over our conversation, another picture that was not being described. It was what my life would have looked like if things had gone according to plan, and how this current situation, far from anywhere I had ever imagined, may or may not have differed from that plan, which might also inform whether or not I was doing OK, and, therefore, whether or not my father needed to worry. It was this second picture, this other life that we were talking around, and the extent to which my present life may or may not have varied from it that our conversation was also about.
我记得有一次，我感觉自己理解了关于另一位死去配偶的事情。那个女人没有描述她的配偶，而是描述了一个电动剃须刀。它属于她丈夫，他很多个早上都在使用它。她曾经讨厌那噪音，但现在他去世了，她醒来时竟怀念那愚蠢东西的声音。不知何故，他那时对我活了起来，尽管这个细节很常规，并没有使他出众。她把剃须刀握在手里，为我们打开了开关。
I remember one time when I felt I understood something about one of the other dead spouses. Instead of her spouse, a woman described an electric razor. It had belonged to her husband, and he had used it on many mornings. She used to hate the noise, but now that he was dead, she missed the sound of the stupid thing when she woke up. Somehow, he came alive to me then, though this detail was routine and did not distinguish him. She held the razor in her hand and flipped it on for us.
人们想知道她长什么样。孩子们尤其想看照片。但在她生命的最后五年里，我妻子最引人注意的特征通常与癌症或治疗有关。她不止一次失去又长回头发，有时戴着轮流更换的假发，没有一顶真正适合她。她的体重经历了巨大的增减，随着时间推移，她的脸肿胀了。当人们看她那些年的照片时，往往先看到一个病人，而在其他时候，人们会看到一个充满活力和健康的人。我不确定该描述哪个版本。
People want to know what she looked like. Children especially want to see pictures. But in the last five years of her life, my wife's most noticeable characteristics were often related to either cancer or treatment. She lost and regrew her hair more than once and sometimes wore a rotation of wigs, none of which quite suited her. She gained and lost large amounts of weight, and over time, her face swelled. When one looks at a picture of her from these years, one often sees a sick person before anything else, while at other times, one sees someone vibrant and healthy. I am not sure which version to describe.
更多变量——她被诊断出IV期癌症时28岁，33岁去世。她的驾照上说她身高5英尺6英寸，体重115磅，棕发绿眼——尽管体重不准确，也许是她十几岁时填写的那些资料，沿用了多年。随着她生病，体重降至远低于那个数字，它又变得准确了。
More variables-- she was 28 when she was diagnosed with stage IV cancer, 33 when she died. Her driver's license says she was 5 foot 6 and 115 pounds, with brown hair and green eyes-- although the weight was incorrect, perhaps one of those things she had filled out as a teenager and carried over for years. It became correct again as she sickened and then dropped well below that number.
在我的记忆中，她的眼睛比记录中的绿色更偏棕色。我可以这样说，当她健康时，她的头发很细，通常不会超过肩长，有时戴着发带，通常没长到可以扎起来，尽管我不看照片甚至不能确定最后一点。她年轻时，她爸爸经常取笑她头很大。有时我说她是白人，但通常，我等到被问到。有时我嫉妒那个有死去的配偶的白人，因为被问到那个问题的可能性较小。
In my memory, her eyes are more brown than the green that was documented. I could say that when she was healthy, her hair was thin, often not much longer than shoulder length, sometimes worn with a headband and usually not long enough to tie up, although I can't even be sure about this last part without checking photographs. When she was young, her dad used to tease her about having a big head. Sometimes I offer that she was white, but usually, I wait until the question is asked. Sometimes I envy the white person with a dead spouse, of whom the question would be less likely to be asked.
在悼词中，我描述了我觉得她最与众不同的地方——当她感受深刻时，她周围的空气会改变和静止，整个身体做出反应，无论她是在看大海、布料的染料还是记忆。在这些时刻，她可能会低语或哭泣。我觉得如果我触摸她的皮肤，她会变成蒸汽。
In her eulogy, I described the thing about her that I found most distinctive-- the way the air around her would transform and still and her entire body react when she felt something deeply, whether she was encountering a view of the ocean, the dye of a fabric, a memory. In these moments, she might whisper or cry. And I felt that if I touched her skin, she would dissolve into vapor.
在那些时刻，我也能看到那个对世界太敏感的孩子。在家族传说中，她曾是个问题少年，情绪化、不可安慰，容易发脾气。一种正义感伴随着她的一生，有时仍然让她不知所措。也许正因如此，她对性格的判断迅速而坚定。她给了我一份她不想出现在葬礼上的人名单。
In those moments, I could also see the young child who had been too sensitive to the world. In family lore, she had been a problem child, emotional and inconsolable, prone to tantrums. A sense of injustice followed her throughout her life and still got the better of her sometimes. Perhaps for this reason, she was a quick and firm judge of character. She gave me a list of people she did not want at her memorial.
我也可以描述那些在长时间关注后才显露出来的较不明显的区别，她走近认识的人时会轻轻歪头打招呼，睡觉时她会把胳膊举到空中，慢慢挠这一只，然后那一只，飞机起飞前她会变得紧张并伸手抓我的手。
I can also describe those less obvious distinctions that reveal themselves only after long periods of attention, that she tilted her head slightly as a greeting when she walked toward someone she knew, that in her sleep, she raised her arms into the air and slowly scratched one and then the other, that she became nervous and reached for my hand when an airplane was about to take off.
然而，这些细节越来越让人觉得无关紧要。随着时间流逝，她对我来说变得更多，那些让她和别人一样的东西。我想到两只胳膊、两只耳朵和一个有时流鼻涕的鼻子。她有袜子和围巾，洗澡后裹着毛巾，写卡片，乘公共汽车，绕过水坑，拉开和拉上窗帘，倾听并提问，感到饥饿和疲倦，有时穿运动鞋。她和任何人一样，也就是说，仅仅通过呼吸，她创造了生命和氛围。
Yet, increasingly, these details feel irrelevant. As time passes, she becomes more to me, the things that made her just like other people. I think of two arms and two ears and a nose that sometimes ran. She owned socks and scarves, wrapped a towel around herself after a shower, wrote cards, rode the bus, walked around puddles, opened and closed curtains, listened and asked questions, got hungry and tired, sometimes wore sneakers. She was like anyone else, which is to say that simply by breathing, she created life and atmosphere.
这对我来说越来越像是重点，对事物本身的描述，而不是是什么让它不同。我将尝试描述我一生中最幸福的一天之一。我和伴侣离开医院。她经历了第一年的手术、康复、药物治疗。她手里拿着一份放射科报告的打印件。它描述了她身体、头部、胸部、腹部、骨盆的扫描图像。四次扫描中的每一次报告给出了以下描述——无异常，无异常，无异常，无异常。这一天，关于她没有什么值得描述的。
This increasingly seems to me the point, the description of the thing itself, rather than what makes it different. I will try to describe one of the happiest days of my life. My partner and I are leaving the hospital. She has been through her first year of surgery, recovery, drug treatment. She holds in her hand the printout of a radiology report. It describes scanned images of her body, of her head, chest, abdomen, pelvis. The report for each of the four scans gives the following descriptions-- unremarkable, unremarkable, unremarkable, unremarkable. On this day, there is nothing about her worth describing.
阿尔弗雷德·荣格·李是爱荷华城的作家。这篇文章最初发表在《The Believer》杂志上。我们的版本由黛安·吴制作。
Alfred Jung Lee is a writer in Iowa City. This essay was originally published in The Believer. Our version was produced by Diane Wu.
好吧，今天的节目，担任制作人标签的人是我。由我们的执行编辑伊曼纽尔·贝里编辑。参与今天节目录制的人包括菲亚·本宁、达娜·齐维斯、伊曼纽尔·多齐、卡西·豪利、阿德里安·莉莉、塞思·林德、莫莉·马塞洛、安德里亚·马克斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、鲁比·施瓦茨、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。
Well, today's show, the person holding the label of producer was me. It was edited by our executive editor, Emanuele Berry. The people who put today's show together include Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Cassie Howley, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Molly Marcello, Andrea Marks, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Ruby Schwartz, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala.
我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑，大卫·肯斯特鲍姆和南希·厄普代克。特别感谢本周的贝琪·约翰逊、艾伦·菲利普斯、琳赛·内德和自闭症之声的玛尔塔·奇米洛维奇、科里·安德烈亚斯、吴世恩（音译）、Leading Age、梅丽莎·霍尼格、伊芙琳·马特、阿米娜·杜布森、伊夫·维拉斯，以及与我们分享经历的其他TPS工人们。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editors, David Kestenbaum and Nancy Updike. Special thanks this week to Betsy Johnson, Allan Phillips, Lindsay Naeder, and Marta Chmielowicz at Autism Speaks, Kory Andreas, Se Eun Gong, Leading Age, Melissa Honig, Evelyn Marte, Amina Dubuisson, Yves Vilas, and the other workers on TPS who shared their experiences with us.
也感谢我们所有的《美国生活》合作伙伴。他们的支持是我们预算的重要组成部分。订阅成为“生活伙伴”，您将获得定期、独家的额外剧集。您可以无广告收听。并将帮助我们继续制作这个节目。请在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 加入。该链接也在节目说明中。
Thanks, also, to all of our This American Life Partners. Their support is an essential part of our budget. Subscribe as a Life Partner, and you'll get regular, exclusive bonus episodes. You'll listen ad-free. And you'll help us continue to make the show. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我的老板，伊拉·格拉斯。他这周休假，正在制作他的新电台节目《那个美国生活》。他说我们的节目是旧闻了。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He's off this week, working on his new radio show, That American Life. He says our show is old news.
我说：“我早就知道了。为什么我们要谈这个？”
I'm like, I already know this. Why are we talking about this?
我是托宾·洛。伊拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Tobin Low. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
[音乐播放]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放中]